une rue calme et tranquille dans 15e
rien n'indique mais elle abrite sans
doute le lieu le plus cosmopolite de
paris dewey journalistes congolais
depuis six mois qu'il est là c'est l'un
des plus anciens du bâtiment ici c'est
la maison des journalistes ou mdj pour
les intimes refuge unique au monde pour
reporter en exil visite guidée des fêtes
de mariage de jeu du désordre c'est pour
ça aussi je pense souvent à ma femme
parce que ça cesse et ses autres vols
ou la plupart arrivent abattu moralement
d'abord parfois physiquement il y en a
qui arrivent ici après avoir passé deux
semaines dans le métro
vous avoir passé une période sans manger
attentes nuit à la belle étoile tout ici
réside 15 journalistes des eaux nous
présente ses voisins de chambrée
je suis
à
se réfugier journaliste iranienne
appreniez
afghan yemini cubain leur présence ici
est un pied-de-nez aux dictatures qui
ont voulu les faire taire bienvenue à la
mdj financement presse française europe
et mairie de paris qui a pas cité
d'accueil 30 personnes par an avec un
seul critère d'admission être reporter
menacés dans l'exercice de son métier
l'une des salles portant
chacun sa popote
qui est là mais c'est un ami de ceux
encore l'or
s'est envolé du sri-lanka en janvier
2008 est resté en un et trois mois il
n'est pas prêt on a passé trois mois au
népal puis du népal on est venu en
france
mais on peut pas retourner là bas si on
y retourne tu découvriras nos cadavres
dans les médias
tous ici ont été victimes ou témoins
d'exactions en plus de la chambre des
tickets resto la mdj leur fournit une
assistance psychologique et social ils
ont un délai de six mois pour décrocher
le statut de réfugié et qui sait
rapatrier leurs familles on voit ici
mais je ne sais pas est un exemple je ne
sais pas c'est mes enfants ont mangé
aussi c'est ils ont reçu des menaces est
tout content qu'on ne peut pas être
complètement heureux quoi des eaux
menacé de mort au congo a mis à l'abri
sa femme et ses six enfants dans un pays
voisin il paye une carrière consacrée à
relater les malheurs d'un peuple qui a
perdu en dix ans près de 5 millions
d'âmes la guerre civile les crimes
gratuits il a tout vu la mdj lui donne
l'occasion de les raconter elle organise
des rencontres avec les lycéens de
france aujourd'hui c'est à vendôme dans
le loir et cher le matin
vers 6 heures du matin que les premières
personnes qui vont au travail ou à
l'école ont découvert mon frère baignant
dans une heure dans une mare de sang
aurait tiré une balle ici qui est
ressortie par l'un et il était donc le
septième journaliste être assassiné en
trois ou quatre ans les salles au pardon
excusez moi des meurtriers donc pour ces
lycéens le témoignage de déo c'est une
réalité bien loin de leur quotidien qui
s'imposent à eux
l'an dernier dans le monde 121
journalistes ont été tués telle
impression ça vous fait de ne voit que
dans d'autres contrées
le travail de journaliste et si c'est
difficile c'est
dangereux si périlleux c'est qu'il ya
certaine censure mais pas au point de ne
rien pouvoir dire
au point de tuer le jouer voilà
facilement vous espérez que ça
s'améliore dans votre pays c'est pas
demain la veille malheureusement c'est
pas demain la veille parce que
malheureusement cela qu'ils sont au
pouvoir
ne sont pas prêts à le lâcher
grâce à sa plume et au réseau de la
régie des eaux a trouvé un job comme
porte parole de l'association mondiale
des journalistes il restera donc dans le
métier sur 180 réfugiés accueillis par
la mdj seule une quinzaine est encore
reporter l une des exceptions les plus
remarquables est passé par la maison il
ya six ans son nom soro solo ils causent
tous les dimanches à la radio bon
j'aurais
aujourd'hui on vous emmène en guinée
conakry un pays qu'on ne dirige contre
a- et aujourd'hui l'émission de soro et
de son pote vlad cartonne sur les ondes
il était loin de s'imaginer tout ça
quand il a échappé au béret noir en côte
d'ivoire loin aussi de s'imaginer que
son passage mdj marquerait pour lui le
début d'une nouvelle vie
j'imagine un peu j'avais quand même
faire 25 ans verra de démonter tout
s'arrête et à plus de 50 ans passés je
viens de coinchée et notre vie
professionnelle enfants ce paradoxe a
pas de boulot pas de perspectives pour
la jeunesse y compris quand elle a fait
des études en 2009 une quarantaine de
journalistes sont passés de l'exil à
l'asile sur le territoire français comme
solo ces damnés de la presse ont leur
métier et leur pays chevillée au corps
alors les jours où ce régime n'est plus
là où j'aime simplement ma vie menacé en
cas du bois germa sur la france et je
retournerai dans mon pays